the movie revolves around a father sang
Tay and his teenage daughter do Yan who
reside in a small town in South Korea
senke loves his daughter a lot and works
hard to provide her with a good life but
doyon is a spoiled brat all she cares
about is her reputation at school Under
makeup products moreover she tries to
avoid her dad the best she can whether
it be at home while heading to school or
at a relative's house sangte's wife Kim
knows about the problem but she believes
that the girl is acting weird simply
because of her adolescent face one day
do yawn's grandfather gets sick so the
family decides to visit him even there
though Jan ignores her dad and keeps on
chatting with her friends a while later
she gets up and prepares to leave so
Sankey is forced to escort her home
outside sangtay becomes emotional and
asks his daughter if he has done
anything wrong he mentions that he works
day and night to fulfill her demands yet
she doesn't even see him as a father
hearing this the spoiled doe Yan replies
that she is always misunderstood and
that it is very hard to be a student
sangte asserts that student life is easy
challenges her to live his life for a
day as the two are arguing Grandpa pops
up out of nowhere and shows his ginkgo
tree he mentions that if one prays near
this tree their wishes can be fulfilled
but sadly when he turns back he realizes
that no one was listening to him
elsewhere though Yan and sangte are
still arguing on their way back home as
the latter tries to make his daughter
understand he has a tiny lapse in
concentration and ends up crashing his
car into an oncoming truck drinking and
driving is one thing but having shitty
kids and driving is the riskiest when
the two wake up at the hospital they're
shocked to find out that their bodies
have been switched it appears as if the
magical ginkgo tree switched their
positions something which they were
arguing about wasting no time they head
to an isolated section of the hospital
and try to make sense of the situation
sangte in his daughter's body assumes
that God has punished them for being
Reckless but doyon in her dad's body
asserts that there has to be a logical
explanation behind it just then sangte
remembers his doctor friend Lee and
decides to pay him a visit the two then
escape the hospital and get inside a cab
on the way doyon calls sangtay dad and
also keeps acting like a girl as
expected this confuses the cab driver
and he assumes that the two are mental
patients in the next scene dohyan and
senkai arrive at Lee's office and the
latter who is in his daughter's body
starts pleading for help please doctor
tell my daughter to give me my penis
back to prove that he is actually saying
Tay he also reveals some of Lee's
darkest Secrets however instead of
believing them Lee becomes enraged and
scolds sangtay for divulging their
secrets and before the father and
daughter can say anything he forces them
out of his office shortly after the two
reach a pharmacy and again cause a scene
there as a result they decide to keep
their switch a secret from everyone
including their mother later during
dinner Kim serves delicious beef to her
family but sangtay can't have it as his
daughter is on a diet on the other hand
dojon who has never tried alcohol is
forced to drink some when her mother
starts suspecting the two things go from
bad to worse for doyon when her own
mother tries to have intercourse with
her at night fortunately Kim is so drunk
that she falls asleep before any damage
is done this movie is like if Doctor
Strange had an Oedipus complex the next
morning the two get up early and start
researching on how to get their bodies
back but sadly there is no information
about it anywhere after a while they
meet in the basement and blame each
other for their woes just then sangte
remembers that their creepy old grandpa
knows a great deal of stuff about the
supernatural he immediately calls him
and the Old Man reveals that the switch
has been made possible because of the
ginkgo tree he also mentions that
although the switch only lasts for a
week sangtan doyan have to be careful as
if they fight again there will be dire
consequences with this information the
two become relieved but they still have
to go through the entire week which is
extremely important for them senke has
an important presentation coming up at
his workplace while though yawn has been
selected for a once in a lifetime
audition at a musical Club the audition
is extra special because it is taken by
none other than her Crush go hence they
mutually decide to continue each other's
lives by learning their respective
habits and way of living that if you
don't kiss that dude you're gonna ruin
my life shortly after sangtan doyan get
ready and head to the school and office
respectively on the way they teach each
other how to behave and even replace
their phones to look more authentic when
do yawn reaches her dad's office she
finds out that he is really unpopular he
works for a Cosmetics company and
manages a small deadbeat team which is
known as team powder which is apparently
about to be laid off due to lack of
sales among his team are the assistant
manager Jang Wan an irritating but
responsible employee and sales executive
na a beautiful woman who looks more like
a model than a sales girl a while later
team powder has a small discussion where
jangwon tries to explain a presentation
but Dion is busy chatting with her
friends this angers the team as they
have an important meeting with a VIP
investor Quan that evening on the other
hand senke reaches his daughter's school
and sits beside the most obedient
student in class kyung me this confuses
everyone as doyon is notorious for being
arrogant and rude to the obedient
students later he heads to the
auditorium where the audition to the
musical Club is taking place sangte
notices his daughter's Crush go and
immediately grows a dislike for him
however when he is called upon the stage
to sing he remembers his teenage years
and gets into the groove sangtay in his
daughter's body grabs a guitar and
starts performing a funky song which
impresses all the judges including Geo
meanwhile team powder is having dinner
with Quan and all the members are trying
their best to suck up to him so that he
will agree to the deal however though
Yawn is uninterested in her father's
Affairs and keeps on using her phone
witnessing this a drunk Quan mentions
that he will sign the contract but only
if saying hey I.E though yawn sings
karaoke and scores above 96. normally
doyon doesn't care about helping others
but since a teen like her is big into
karaoke she immediately agrees she then
goes on the stage and performs a
dazzling show which gets her a
near-perfect score of 97. this Delights
the group and the contract is secured at
night the father-daughter Duo catches up
and briefs each other about their first
day sang Tay becomes angry when he
learns that his daughter danced in front
of his team however he can do nothing
more than smile at her as quarreling
will cause dire implications for them
the following day at school senke learns
that a class test is going to be
conducted the next day so he requests
the obedient girl kyung me to help him
at first kyungi refuses claiming that
she doesn't like socializing with others
but when sangte insists she eventually
agrees that night the girls study hard
for their task and promise to get the
best grades elsewhere though Yan starts
bonding with na over their shared
interest in cosmetic items after a while
she returns home and finds her dad
spending time with her friends enraged
she confronts saying Tay for bringing
over her friends but the latter mentions
that it's for their upcoming task
hearing this doyon scoffs at her dad and
mentions that it's very hard to get good
grades but being the competitive guy
that he is senke promises that he will
Top the class sadly during the task when
he checks the question paper he finds
out that he can't answer even a single
question sangte then spends the next
hour just coloring his answer paper like
a kid on the other hand doyon learns
from Team powder that a Marketing Group
is on their way to the office to shoot
an advertisement for lipstick doyon
tries to wriggle her way out of the
situation but when jangwon mentions that
their team is leading the advertisement
she has no choice but to get involved
later as the entire team gets ready
disaster strikes the marketing team has
met with an accident so one of the team
powder's staff will have to face the
camera and endorse the lipstick
themselves both jangwon and na are
scared of facing cameras so they refuse
to take part in it hence with no options
left doyon in her father's body is
forced to complete the shoot to make
matters worse the advertisements being
shot live on air with the entire country
watching it closely but surprisingly
though yawn using her impeccable
knowledge of cosmetic items endorses the
lipstick flawlessly and impresses the
bosses however before she can celebrate
she gets a call from the school
revealing that her father did awfully
bad in her text enraged doyon heads
straight to the staff room and start to
berating her dad in front of the teacher
she even hits him several times but
instead of fighting back like he always
does sangtay simply runs away outside
the two reconcile and promise to not
mess up each other's lives again doyon
reveals that her Crush Geo has invited
her for a date the next evening and it
is an opportunity that she simply cannot
miss she then pleads with her dad to go
on the date and impress go expectedly
sanctui declines right away claiming
that he doesn't even like the boy in the
first place but since doyon is a
stubborn girl she eventually convinces
him to date her Crush sounds like sang
Tay's going to jail the next evening
sengthe and jio wander around the
streets while an anxious doyon stalks
them from behind soon Geo takes him to a
music store where they start bonding
over their common interest in vintage
music after the date is over Geo and Sen
Tay board a boss to return home doyon
also sneaks in and when she notices her
dad very close with her Crush she
becomes envious but when she realizes
that at least the date went well she
consoles herself and smiles it is now
day six since the switch it is also the
most important day for saying Tay as he
is supposed to deliver Stellar
presentation in front of his boss and
the board of directors it turns out that
the fate of the entire team powder
depends on the presentation meaning that
if sangtay doesn't impress the directors
all of them will be fired before
departing sangte encourages his daughter
for the presentation and wishes her good
luck he then heads to school and waits
anxiously for the decisive moment a few
hours later doyon reaches the office
where several investors the board of
directors and other dignitaries are all
waiting team powder also sits in a
corner hopeful that their manager can
deliver a powerful speech and save their
jobs at the same time senke sneaks out
of his class and calls his daughter to
listen in on the entire presentation
soon doyon commences Her speech and
using her vast knowledge of Cosmetics
impresses everyone but just when
everyone starts to applaud her she flips
the speech right on its head and asserts
that the company's products are too
expensive she mentions that teenagers
are not stupid to buy such expensive
products so it would be better to lower
the cost for better results in this way
doyon speaks about the day-to-day
problems that she faces while buying and
cosmetic items sadly the bods are far
from impressed by the suggestion and
they decide to terminate team powder
with immediate effect sangtay who is
hearing all this from his phone gets
devastated he immediately runs to the
office and confronts his daughter for
her stupidity but the latter shouted him
for never listening to her opinions she
doesn't realize that that's because her
opinions are stupid she then walks away
without giving her dad a chance to
explain the next day doyon again heads
to the office and tries to convince the
bods to reconsider their decision she
even gets on her knees and begs them
however all this simply infuriates the
directors and they request that she go
away still unwilling to give up though
yawn starts chasing after their car and
at the same time sangte arrives on a
bicycle sadly during the commotion the
car strikes the bicycle knocking sang
Tay out he is immediately taken to the
hospital where do Yan starts crying she
then takes out her phone and starts
going through her childhood photos where
sangtay is always by her side that night
the ginkgo tree sheds a leaf which
travels all the way to the hospital
besides sanctu's bed it then performs a
special magic and finally reverts the
father and daughter back to their
original bodies then doyon dies
just kidding the next morning when
sangte and doyan wake up they are
ecstatic to have their bodies back they
then hug each other tightly before
venturing out of the hospital in the
final scene sangte gets a call from Jang
Wan informing him that the board of
directors have reconsidered their
decision and reinstated team powder
their salaries have also been increased
for their controversial but bold
suggestions the movie ends as do yhan
and sengthe take a selfie together
indicating that their bond is stronger
than ever the moral of the story is if
you want your daughter to like you just
fake your death subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching